bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
Sonia je commence avec vous ça a pris
deux heures et demie au juré au 9 jurés
dans la district de Manhattan ça a été
très rapide manifestement le plaidoyer
de l'équipe de madame Carole était au
point là
oui c'est vrai que certains
s'attendaient à avoir peut-être la
décision un peu plus tard donc ça a été
assez rapide le ce jury qui était
composé de 6 hommes et trois femmes qui
sont anonymes et bien à pris sa décision
à l'unanimité dans ce process civil je
le rappelle et du coup on a eu cette ce
cette
leur décision qui a été que selon eux
les avocats de la plaignante ont réussi
à prouver que Donald Trump avait agressé
sexuellement et diffamé et Jean Carole
et d'une Carole qui accusait Donald
Trump de viol finalement donc le jury a
décidé que selon l'épreuve et elle avait
été agressée sexuellement mais vous
l'avez dit on l'a vu sortir de ce
tribunal le sourire aux lèvres avec son
avocate qui a dit
qu'elles étaient très heureuses et donc
c'est une victoire pour cette plaignante
de 79 ans qui finalement
porte un coup à l'image de Donald Trump
alors Raphaël c'est je le rappelle c'est
un tribunal civil il n'a pas été reconnu
coupable devant une cour criminelle donc
c'est pour ça qu'on dit qu'il est
responsable il devra néanmoins bon il va
porter la cause en appel devra néanmoins
en principe payer 5 millions de dollars
c'est quand même un coup dur monsieur
Trump disait je la connais pas
ça s'était pas assez dans une cabine
d'essayage dans un grand magasin de New
York en 1996 alors personne n'a cru les
9 jurés entre non pas cru la Rebuffat et
le plaidoyer de trap c'est un coup de
jupe Patrice d'un point de vue ne
serait-ce qu'historique dans la mesure
où ma mère de ma connaissance et aucun
réel précédent pour ça peut-être celui
qu'on a qui est le plus proche à la fois
en terme de ressemblance et d'un point
de vue temporel dans le temps c'est
bettington qui avait réglé hors cours
avec une femme qui s'appelait Paula
Jones qu'il avait accusé dans les années
90 ont un petit peu dans les mêmes eaux
là ils conduisent sexuel etc mais
justement c'était un règlement hors
cours on avait pas eu un verdict de ses
pairs et lorsqu'on parle des pères de
Donald Trump c'est carrément ça à New
York aujourd'hui c'est sa ville
d'origine c'est la ville qui l'a en
bonne partie rendue célèbre en premier
lieu donc d'un point de vue historique
c'est vrai que c'est majeur d'avoir un
ex-président actuel candidat d'ailleurs
en fait actuellement meneur pour
emporter à nouveau l'investisseur
présidentielle de son parti aveur en vue
des prochaines élections qui se fait
reconnaître comme vous dites responsable
au civil dans un une cause d'assart
c'est pas rien d'un point de vue
politique d'un point de vue électoral je
vous l'ai dit dans le passé lorsqu'on
s'est parlé des accusations criminelles
qu'on avait déposées contre lui il y a
quelques semaines que si c'était pour
avoir un impact ça serait en fait
positif pour lui c'est exactement ce
qu'on a observait dans ce cas-ci je
serai surpris qu'il y a un impact énorme
d'un côté ou de l'autre le pignon public
à ce stade-ci elle est presque
entièrement cristallisée au sujet de
Monsieur Trump et c'est sondages sont
assez bons souvenirs êtes-vous d'accord
dans l'analyse politique que le coût
politique sera pas énorme étonnamment
parce qu'on imagine au Canada on imagine
même dans d'autres pays
un candidat serait fini là il rentrera
chez lui or monsieur Trump va continuer
la course vraisemblablement Sonia Dridi
oui c'est vrai alors c'est vrai que on
l'a vu en ces dernières années les
affaires finalement Donald Trump est
très peu impacté par toutes les affaires
judiciaires qui le concernent et parfois
il en sort même renforcé on l'a vu avec
le dernier procès qui qui concernait
Donald Trump il y a quelques semaines
vous l'avez dit il est il a toujours la
côte dans les sondages selon un dernier
sondage national il est même il est à
même un peu plus au dessus que Joe Biden
toutefois on commence tout de même à
sentir un petit peu le vent tourner
alors on le sait chez les républicains
il y a beaucoup notamment chez l'élite
républicaine traditionnelle de gens qui
en ont marre de Donald Trump mais qui ne
savent pas comment s'en débarrasser qui
n'osent pas le dire publiquement parce
que sinon pour les élus et bien ça peut
leur coûter cher toutefois on commence à
entendre aujourd'hui sur Fox News
notamment qui a été la chaîne qui a très
longtemps soutenu
simplement Donald Trump il y a des
observateurs qui commençaient à dire ça
fait beaucoup et c'est vrai que quand
même même si
ça va pas les les pro Trump les Maga
comme on les appelle ne vont pas changer
d'avis sur Donald Trump mais pour une
élection générale pour l'élection qui
l'opposera s'il est le nominé
républicain probablement à Joe Biden
pour 2024 et bien faut aussi avoir le
vote des électeurs indépendants et je
pense que là ça commence à se compliquer
je pense qu'il y a quand même des
électeurs notamment les électeurs
indépendants qui qui en ont marre de
toutes ces affaires et surtout là il a
été condamné enfin il a été jugé
responsable puisque c'est un procès
civile mais là c'est quand même assez
clair il y a cette étiquette qui va lui
coller à la peau pendant toute la
campagne et je pense que au sein du
parti républicain aujourd'hui il y a
quand même beaucoup d'inquiétudes et
c'est toute la question c'est une
élection générale là il devient un
candidat de plus en plus faible
Rafael êtes-vous d'accord que ça peut
quand même
bon jusqu'ici n'a pas été embêter dans
les sondages par les affaires mais là
c'est quand même une décision claire
nette précise à New York ça peut pas
percoler dans la population chez les
électeurs chez les femmes pendant de
dire ça fait peut-être beaucoup là en
fait je voudrais Patrice que ça a déjà
percolé vous savez et c'est là que la
nuance elle est drôlement importante
lorsqu'on présente dans notre chambre
comme étant un candidat téflon ou un
policier téflon c'est vrai ça ne l'est
pas ça veut dire que c'est largement
vrai à se stadie pourquoi parce qu'on a
tellement eu de controverse délégation
de scandale de déclaration choc et très
rapidement dans le temps dès dans le
champ est devenu un policier national en
2015 l'opinion publique c'est rapidement
braqué d'un côté ou de l'autre parce que
justement il y avait déjà tellement de
matière qui faisait en sorte qu'on
essaie d'un côté ou de l'autre qu'une
fois qu'un opinion était faite elle est
bien elle était faite de façon quasi
définitive qu'à ce stade-ci il est
presque essentiellement presque
entièrement téflon donc est-ce que ça
peut percoler de façon marginale
peut-être à terme auprès des électeurs
indépendants qui ne se sont pas eux fait
entièrement une taille
on va regarder un sondage
est-ce que c'est le NBC celui-là
Washington
regardez Joe Biden 32 a-t-il la vivacité
d'esprit on demande 32 est-il assez
bonne santé physique pour être président
33 dans leur tramp le surclasse c'est
deux questions quand même vitales Sonia
Dridi
c'est quand même révélateur non
oui alors il est clair que Donald Trump
qui a deux ans de moins que Joe Biden
apparaît beaucoup plus en forme plus
dynamique que Joe Biden ça je pense que
même les démocrates beaucoup vous le
diront mais Joe Biden si encore une fois
c'est Donald Trump qui est le nominé et
Joe Biden côté démocrate Joe Biden a
déjà remporté une élection contre Donald
Trump et là encore une fois même si
Donald Trump va ne déçoit pas sa base
qui veut dire la base de Donald Trump
c'est un peu comme un culte cette cette
histoire cette affaire beaucoup vont
trouver des excuses vont croire Donald
Trump qui n'a jamais vu
ID Jean Caroll qui sait pas du tout
c'est qui mais encore une fois je pense
que une élection générale ça
peut lui faire mal et je peux vous dire
qu'au sein du parti républicain il y a
des gens il y a des gens qui sont
embêtés on va on va reparler Sonia
dready merci beaucoup à avoir shington
Raphaël on se parle tous les vendredis
on aura le temps d'en parler également
merci beaucoup à vous deux bonne soirée
merci